bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous certes et france quel regard est ce
que vous portez sur cette journée de
mobilisation hier
bonjour c'est une journée importante
puisqu'elle intervient au coeur du débat
du secteur de la santé afin de porter le
concrètement les revendications de
l'ensemble de la profession et plus
particulièrement de l'hôpital public
je tiens à rappeler que ça fait
maintenant plus de 20 ans que dans le
secteur de la santé nous avons des
difficultés majeures et notamment de
reconnaissance des métiers de la santé
en termes de qualification et de
revalorisation salariale
donc quand nous arriverons à une forme
de ras-le-bol qui est exacerbée en
raison de la crise sanitaire les
soignants des teams hier en avant ils se
sont beaucoup investis et aujourd'hui
demandent que le retour leur soit fait
par rapport à sainté investissements et
au delà même de la revalorisation des
salaires des qualifications et de leurs
conditions de travail
c'est qu'il puisse y avoir des crises à
sion à court terme mais je suis au sein
de la mission de la santé une démarche à
moyen et long terme pour la politique de
santé dans notre pays vous venez
d'évoquer à nouveau de savoir en plein
ségur de la santé et discussions et
négociations ont commencé il ya quelques
semaines elles vont se prolonger ou est
ce qu'elles sont c'est ces discussions
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez le
sentiment qu'elles répondent aux
attentes des soignants ou en tout cas
qu'elles violent sa direction
pour l'instant je suis bien en peine de
vous répondre précisément là on en sort
très concrètement puisque il ya de très
nombreuses réunions avec l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé l'ensemble des
corps médicaux de façon séparée au
travers aussi du goût de travail
particulier et tout cela doit se
retrouver au sein des deux séances
plénières en présence du ministre pour
un peu faire la synthèse et voir quel
est l'état d'avancée de la situation
donc pour l'instant on n'a pas
d'éléments concrets et nous espérons
parce que c'est une nécessité pour les
questions de santé dans notre pays que
je gouvernement prendra les mesures très
concrètes et très rapide pour régler une
bonne fois pour toutes la situation la
santé dans notre pays justement la crise
sanitaire à rêver de nombreuses
défaillances
notre structure hospitalière comment est
ce que il faut s'y prendre aujourd'hui
pour reconstruire le système de santé
déjà il faut revoir j'allais dire
l'idéologie politique parce que comme je
disais tout à l'heure ça fait maintenant
plus de 20 ans que l'on applique à
l'hôpital public notamment les systèmes
de gestion que l'on connaît dans les
entreprises privées
or on ne gère pas la santé globalement
et encore moins un tel public par
exemple comme on gère une entreprise
il y avait bien demandé des actes de
gestion à avoir mais d'abord en termes
de santé il faudrait examiner quels sont
les besoins de la population
est ce que l'on met en oeuvre pour y
répondre or depuis plus de 20 ans encore
une fois systématiquement ce sont des
mesures d'austérité qui sont mis en
place afin d'avoir un premier temps de
fermer des lits puis ensuite de fermer
des services
on a eu le cas des maternités souvenez
vous ou pour des raisons de sécurité on
fermer des maternités mais avant cela
tout a été fait pour c'est la cyclo de
ces maternités ne sera plus assuré et de
se retrouver ainsi au bout du bout dans
entre guillemets l'obligation de fermer
ces maternités dernier de même
d'ailleurs pour certains secteurs de
l'hôpital
donc ce qu'il faut remettre encore en
avance et les moyens nécessaires pour
faire fonctionner l'ensemble de la santé
dans notre dans notre pays et justement
400 savoyard alors dont l'hôpital public
a besoin aujourd'hui
alors j'ai dit venir vous c'est il ya
deux c'est assez technique mais je vais
juste que ce site est un exemple nous
sommes gérés par ce qu'on appelle
l'objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance maladie et ses dernières
années en fait depuis la crise la crise
de 2008
cet objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance maladie est limité dans un
premier temps à 2,5 pour cent puis les
passer à 2004 et
donc vous voyez bien que c'est une des
manières de mettre dans un nouveau
d'étranglement les la réponse aux
besoins de santé
en année normale sans aucune épidémie
classique ni une montée importante de la
grippe hivernale par exemple les besoins
santé d'autres pays devraient progresser
deux entre +4 et demi et 5 % et
justement avant la crise financière de
cet ondam objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance-maladie tourner autour de 6%
il a été donc encore une fois très
gravement réduit à l'occasion de la
crise que nous avons connue et donc ça
accentue et déjà les difficultés que
nous connaissions a notamment à
l'hôpital public et c'est pour ça que
nous retrouvons cet ancien situation
aujourd'hui qui encore une fois se
retrouvent exacerbées par la crise
sanitaire
comment enfin voici pour pour contrer le
manque de reconnaissance vont souffre la
profession
ben c'est pas déjà un premier temps en
dehors du fait d'avoir applaudi les
problèmes de santé tous les jours à 20
heures par des augmentations de salaires
s'est réclamé du pied bien longtemps
l'état de santé est complet en dehors de
la crise sanitaire donne beaucoup de
temps pour exercer leur profession et
les salaires ne sont pas un concurrence
du temps donné de l'engagement que donne
l'ensemble des problèmes de santé dans
notre pays lorsque vous faites le
comparatif avec nos voisins européens
et vous savez que nous sommes très
largement en deçà en matière de
reconnaissance salariale
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions serge legagnoa
je rappelle que vous êtes un secrétaire
confédéral chargé de la protection
sociale collective